m
[Musique]
l'été lanaudière vibre généralement au
rythme de la musique classique avec ses
cinquante mille spectateurs joliette et
l'autre plus important festival de
musique classique au canada la région
elle est beaucoup plus connu
historiquement pour ses grands espaces
sa pêche sa motoneige et sentiers de
randonnée que ce terrain et ça a permis
aux gens de constater que la lozère
était aussi une terre de culture fondée
en 1978 par le père fernand lindsay
le festival est devenu en quarante trois
ans un rendez vous estival
incontournable dans ce temps là il n'y
avait pas de concert à montréal l'été il
n'y avait pas de conseils extérieurs
l'ouest en face de votre concert
extérieur
alors vous en fait les quartiers d'été
de leur de l'om à joliette
depuis le festival continue de prendre
de l'ampleur notamment avec la
construction en 1989 de son amphithéâtre
extérieur daft et atmen kelif commune
croquer ouverte vers la montagne et le
mur naturel avec heather faire en sorte
que le leçons sont très bien de quoi
convaincre les plus grands orchestres de
s'y produire
un événement qui a également suscité des
vocations la découverte de la musique
était basé vraiment le sûrement la
fréquentation du festival quand j'étais
enfant quand j'étais adolescent
cette année l'équipe du festival a
replongé dans ses archives pour
ressortir des concerts marquants a
présenté gratuitement en ligne
j'ai essayé de finalement créer un
portrait qui soit représentatif de
l'histoire du festival
on a deux concert d'archivé éléments les
gens vers cet été un concert de renata
scotto la soprano italienne à la
cathédrale joliette un concert de la
soprano green à dijon milieu des années
80 à l'église de saint jean de monts
comme rien de moins à défaut de pouvoir
présenter un spectacle physique la
version connectée est une consolation
qui aura quand même des conséquences
économiques
un exemple tout la restauration à
joliette qui normalement foisonne de
gens qui viennent voir le festival heavy
damas une clientèle qui quand ils vont
le regarder de leur salon on est content
que le regarde quand même dans les
semaines à venir ben ils seront pas
nécessairement à l'eau dans les
restaurants dualité
qu'est ce concert mémorable seront mis
en ligne d'ici le 9 ou pour permettre
aux mélomanes de patienter jusqu'à la
prochaine édition de ce festival qui
mélange nature et culture et ciney bien
lexandre chartier radio canada juliette